[Music]
Bhanu, there
is love, there is more love, so
for us, there is more love for us, there is also love,
we are slowly [
Music]
This is our Rohingya language, so we will have to
learn, study and study ever since Mula ji has been teaching.
We know
[music]
but don't listen because we do
n't listen to it unless we study. I was very fond of it.
This time we studied it ourselves, yet
slowly and gradually we
started teaching this lesson to all the children too.  Did it
[Music]
Ghazal here, at
some place, I am a Maulana, I study in Madras, I have to go to
Patna from my place to another village,
from one village to another village, I
also have to take permission from my beloved
that I am going for a little emergency.  Give
what you give to them and
forgive them even more after listening. Do they have to walk on you?
Once humanity is
not there at all.
Whatever has been said, we are going to lift it up,
meaning that is why we do this in our tongue,
where we are.  I will also teach, but whoever
means the day will have love for the country, whoever means
love for our country, it will not happen
[Music]